in this episode of the stronger by
science podcast we discussed
advancements in athlete drug testing
research pertaining to protein and
overfeeding a surprising new study on FD
steyr own supplementation and which
muscle groups are really targeted by the
back squat then we interviewed dr. Eric
Helms about all things bodybuilding and
we finally settle the dispute about who
truly started the first-ever fitness
podcast thanks for listening and enjoy
[Music]
welcome to the stronger by science
podcast this is your host Eric Trexler
I'm here with temporary guest host Greg
knuckles now before we get into the
science today we have some things we
should probably address don't you think
yeah
well we've always been pretty open and
pretty proud about the fact that we're
the first fitness podcast and this week
some allegations came across our desk
that maybe we are not in fact the first
podcast in the fitness space now people
have been sending us a lot of evidence
suggesting that some podcasts like media
have been available before our first
episode aired and some of these pieces
of media did touch on Fitness related
content now some of this evidence that
people brought to us is very clearly
fabricated this is this is fake news
plain and simple
but it is possible that some of these
things are authentic so I want to start
by saying one thing just like any other
religious text a lot of the things that
happen in the stronger by science
cinematic universe are to be taken
literally and some things need to be
interpreted within the context in which
they're spoken when you agree yeah for
sure so when we say we were the first
fitness podcast you mentioned this and I
thought it was a great point
it is certainly true but not necessarily
factually correct right and that's a
really important distinction but in any
case it takes a really noble /
to assert something that's clearly false
and then when they're forced to
acknowledge it
amid just overwhelming evidence to own
up to that yeah just just to make this
as explicit as possible and clear the
air there were absolutely fitness
podcasts before ours however ours is
still the first fitness podcast and I
don't know how much what do you you
can't get more clearly yeah that's
that's as clear as I know how to make it
now because there were some fitness
related audio pieces of content before
us you gotta admit when you're wrong and
so I'm I'm really proud of us but more
importantly I'm proud of me for stepping
up and doing the right thing and so
that's where we're gonna leave it yeah
okay now there were also allegations
that maybe Greg and I are mad at Omar
and Eric Helms because they started a
copycat fitness podcast and I want to be
very clear about this so that we nip
this rumor in the bud
we are furious we're really upset with
them and if you're listening and we know
you are cuz you're gonna need content
next week Omar Eric you're on notice and
it's gone on long enough and it stops
now now if you're listening you probably
saw the the title of this episode and
notice we are in fact interviewing Eric
Helms this episode that does not mean
that we're cool at all
so if you watch the news you saw this
week Donald J Trump met with Kim jong-un
in the Demilitarized Zone and that's
kind of how we see this you know
sometimes in history you have to meet
and stop and talk with these despicable
characters for the betterment of the
whole world and that's how we view our
conversation with Helms we don't want to
talk to them we didn't like doing it at
the time but it's important yeah our
National Security Advisor advised us
that we shouldn't negotiate with
terrorists and rogue states
but there's there's so much tension in
the air in the fitness industry between
us and Omar and Eric we thought that we
would be the bigger people here and you
know take the opportunity to attempt to
clear the air since they're obviously
you know poor actors acting in bad faith
it's probably gonna go poorly it's
probably going to make relationships
deteriorate even further but you know
it's at least worth a shot it is and
before we move on to the content one
last thing to clarify while we mentioned
that we were the first-ever fitness
podcast we also mentioned that the FDA
rapidly made a press release about CBD
right after we aired our episode about
CBD we suggested that the FDA was
responding directly to us in a prompt
manner and we very much stand by that we
do believe that that federal agencies
are listening and kind of responding
when when we ask them to so again if you
have any federal policies that you want
changed or at least clarified be sure to
send them to us and we will mention them
on the show are we good Greg yes sir I
think we cleared it up I don't know how
much more clear we can make it so that's
that should do it now we have a podcast
eggman on the podcast called feats of
strength it's a fan favorite
Greg would you find this week so the
last time we left off with feats of
strength
it was currently in the middle of IPF
World Championships that will give you
an idea of how much lag time there is
between when we record these episodes
and when they air but but yeah so more
news from the IPF world championships
just for people who weren't keeping tabs
on them Russell Horry broke the IPF
world record total in the 83 kilo class
totalled 833 kilos which is a tremendous
number of pounds also broke the squat
world record in the process and for my
money that was that was definitely one
of the most imp
pressive performances of the entire meet
the 83 kilo class has been stacked for
years now you had John hack before he
left the USA PL you had Brett Gibbs so
you know - very very good lifters have
previously held the world record
Russell Lauri raising the bar still very
young still probably going to improve on
that record in the years to come very
very impressive performance on the
women's side of things
Amanda Lawrence so if you follow
powerlifting on Instagram at all you've
probably seen Amanda Lawrence pop up in
your like on your Instagram feed she is
incredibly strong
squatting mid to high fives regularly in
training she took the IPF world record
squat with 243 kilos which is five
hundred and thirty-five pounds in the 84
kilo class which like for context the
world-record squat in the next weight
class down which is also very impressive
I believe is 202 or 203 kilos from
Isabella Vaughn Weissenberg so that just
gives you kind of context for how
impressive 243 or 535 is in the 84 kilo
class she's tremendously strong you can
watch the video of that squat didn't
even look that hard honestly so
currently I'm pretty sure
Bonita Brown is still the only 600-pound
squatter in drug-tested female
powerlifting but I could see Amanda
Lawrence joining those ranks within the
next year - in the 84 kilo class versus
the supers very very impressive lifts
sticking with squats Alexi nakulan
untested lifter out of Russia 83 kilo
guy he squatted 360 kilos which is 794
pounds at 83 kilos or
183 pounds which like that's just
absolutely bonkers to be clear it was a
gym lift but he currently holds the
world record I believe at 345 kilos so
he's proven that he can hit huge lifts
on the platform before wouldn't be shot
in and also I don't think I mentioned
this that was without knee wraps too so
that's a raw almost 800 pound squat and
body weight of the 180s yeah for for my
money nakulan is probably the most
impressive untested squatter on the
planet right now like that's that's an
absolutely outrageous lift so yeah we we
very well could see an 800 plus pound
Ross squat without knee wraps in that
weight class in the next year or two
which would just be absolutely wild
further sticking with squats so if you
guys haven't picked up on this yet I
really like squats my favorite lifts so
that's what I focus on Cece Ingram also
a gym lift here she competes in both the
72 and 84 kilo classes I believe I think
she's she's closer to the 84 kilo end of
end of that range now but she squatted
645 or 293 kilos
again that was a gym lift that is higher
than her current world-record incredibly
impressive lift there's so I it seems
like on the untested female side of
things a lot of the light weight women
tend to get most of the attention but in
unlike the middle weight / heavy weight
side of things Cece Ingram is just she's
a machine and she's really in a class of
her own right now and that's a just
unbelievably impressive lift moving back
to the IPF Owen Hubbard
215 point 5 kilos which is very close to
500 pounds in the 83 kilo class I
believe yeah yeah that was at 83 which
again new world record outrageously
impressive even in the 105 class if
you're benching anywhere close to 5
that's very much a world class bench so
hitting that at 83
super super impressive I kind of feel
like the feats of strength thus far have
just been kind of an ode to the 83 kilo
class but I mean there's a lot of strong
83 kilo lifters so what can I say about
it
switching gears some of the feedback
we've gotten is that our feats of
strength have been very power lifting
focused so far
I will admit that's my bias I am a power
lifter having competed in any other
strength sports but there are weight
lifters and strongmen who listen to this
podcast so you know for the sake of
ecumenical ISM is that the proper
conjugation whatever doesn't matter that
term in my life
CJ Cummings broke the junior world
record the junior and senior
pan-american records and the junior and
senior American records at junior Pan
Am's recently he snatched 154 in clean
and jerked 193 which I forget how old CJ
is now he's either
I think he's either 16 or 17 but like
for people listening to this podcast who
are not from America I don't think you
fully understand how how blue balled the
US is when it comes to weightlifting and
men winning medals u.s. male hasn't won
Olympic medal in weightlifting in
decades so CJ is a rising star I mean
he's already a star
he won junior Pan Am's he broke the
senior Pan Am record still a teenager
still improving probably doesn't really
have a real shot at winning gold in 2020
but definitely seems like he's strong
enough to be in medal contention
probably for the bronze possibly for the
silver incredibly impressive lifter
improves year-over-year meat over meat
very consistently still young still
going up super super strong guy and then
moving on to the world of strongman if
if you watch world Strongest Man on like
ESPN when it airs like six months after
the actual contest
skip ahead about three minutes because
this is going to be a spoiler if you
didn't know world Strongest Man is
recorded multiple months before it's
actually aired on TV but the reigning
world champion half Thor bjornsen was
taken down by Martin's leases which I
think a lot of people are happy about I
think more people would have been happy
about it if it was under kind of I won't
i won't say like fair circumstances
because like injuries happen but under I
guess like more equitable circumstances
for tore his plantar fascia I believe on
the first day of the finals
still kept competing still did well but
he was hobbled a little bit so like no
one is putting in asterisks by this win
for alesis because I mean strongman is a
fairly dangerous sport even in the
context of strength sports and people do
get injured while competing all the time
but yeah he Martines looked really good
really strong definitely seems like he
he would have still been competitive
with Thor had Thor been healthy and a
lot of people are just really happy
about this because he's if he's a fan
favorite Lisa says
if you don't know who this guy is check
out his YouTube channel like dude just
seems like just a super chill bro like
big goofball doesn't take himself too
seriously just seems like a really nice
genuine guy incredibly strong dude
bringing bringing the gold home to
America which again as an American
making this podcast makes me happy first
since Phil Pfister according on the 3rd
of July no less correct correct
so yeah congratulations to Martines
really really big win for him and you
know honestly I think it makes the sport
of strongman more exciting moving
forward because for the past year or two
man it looked like Thor just had a
stranglehold on the sport and like I
said like Brian Shaw has been a champion
before still very good kind of seems
like he might be on the downslide Thor
is still relatively young as well so I
think a lot of people were kind of
buckling in for well ok this dude just
owns the sport for the next five or six
years so having another very very
top-flight strongman like Lisa's take
the world Strongest Man title you know
still improving looks like the two of
them are going to have a lot of really
really exciting head-to-head battles in
the coming years really really good for
the sport a lot of people are really
happy about it and then on the female
strongman side of things
Riaan on Lovelace dead lifted 260 kilos
in I saw conflicting reports about this
she competes in the 64 kilo class I
think I saw someone say that she missed
weight for the competition and weighed
in at 65
but regardless so one of the things a
lot of people don't know about strongman
if you haven't competed in strongman if
strongman doesn't allow sumo deadlifts
which i think is kind of funny because
strongman allows pretty much everything
else like a lot of a lot of powerlifting
purists get upset at strongman
is like you know they use specialty bars
they allow straps they allow deadlift
suits depending on the event and how
it's set up and whatnot but it's they
allow hitching like it's much more
everything goes than powerlifting for
the most part except that they have like
a hard rule against sumo deadlifts so
one of the things that I think most
people who follow strength sports have
noticed is there are a lot of incredibly
strong lightweight female dead lifters
but basically all of them that I am
aware of pull sumo so Rhian on lovelace
her deadlift was conventional because
she competes in strong and her strong
woman in this case 260 kilos that's like
570 something in that that's the
heaviest conventional deadlift that I've
heard of for any woman in any sport
around that bodyweight so new world
record for her super super impressive
and yeah that uh that wraps up my feats
of strength now feats of strength
usually basically serves as like an
update of the news when it comes to the
strength and power world and this week
there was also some news that that
wasn't a feat of strength but is still
quite relevant you want to give us an
update on that yeah so it came out that
Kelly Branton failed a drug test so if
you don't follow IPF powerlifting kelly
Branton is probably the second best and
if not second best definitely top three
super heavyweight power lifter raw
competing in the IPF would probably be
like a perennial champion were it not
for Ray Williams essentially being God
but yeah it came out that Kelly Branton
failed the drug test that sent a lot of
shock waves through the powerlifting
community
so we what exactly what all did he get
pop for yeah so so here's the deal and
we're we don't specifically want to talk
about Kelly all that much you know I
don't know that he's filed an appeal yet
I don't know that there's been an
investigation so we don't necessarily
want to jump to conclusions we're we're
good we're going to use this as a
framing device to talk about drug
testing generally but I will say things
don't look great for him so he tested
positive for d-ball metabolites when
strong metabolites a growth hormone
secreted Gog and two differents arms and
that definitely doesn't look great
primarily because those are five of the
things that someone would take were they
trying to beat a drug test oh they all
have pretty short half-lives they're the
type of things that someone would take
if they were planning on using drugs and
then cycling off for for a competition
so again until everything comes out
don't want to accuse him of trying to
get away with something untoward but
certainly the way things look now not
great yeah objectively speaking it's
gonna be an uphill battle when he goes
to appeal if he chooses to go that route
yeah yeah so with with that being used
as a framing device do you want to do
you want to hop in talk about drug
testing or yeah I mean this is something
we've talked about a little bit in the
past you know whenever anyone fails a
drug test a lot of times you hear the
conversation goes toward tainted
supplements you know so on a previous
episode we had Rick Collins on and he's
a lawyer who has represented both
athletes and non-athletes in the process
of appealing failed drug tests and you
know he talked about how there was a
case where somebody in the after hours
at a supplement packaging facility was
going in and spiking the supplement with
Clinton
with clenbuterol and he was involved in
a case involving that he's also been
involved in cases where athletes
genuinely have taken supplements they
have retained the leftover like an extra
dose or two of that supplement they send
it off and it turns out yeah that that
supplement actually did contained an
unlisted banned ingredient now we talked
about in a previous podcast a study
showing that there are all these
anabolics on the prohormone market that
you know that the FDA sent out all these
letters and the companies three years
later still still had basically just as
many drugs in these Pro hormones but
these were things that were marketed so
clearly to be anabolic so you just
couldn't miss it yeah I found that mean
we came across a product today called
train bell on which like I'm not saying
that train blonde is spiked with stuff
but like you can't name a product more
cunningly to make people think that it's
trend blown right I'm just saying if
you're taking a product with a name like
that and it turns out it does actually
have [ __ ] in it you really only have
yourself to blame yeah now you you one
of the new things on the block is Psalms
and I actually came across this paper
today by a van Wagoner at all published
in 2017 in the Journal of the American
Medical Association and they looked at a
bunch of products that they bought
online that were being marketed as
Psalms and they looked at 44 products
they found that only 52% of them
contained Psalms another 39 percent
contained some unapproved drug
twenty-five percent of them had
substances that weren't listed on the
label nine percent had no active
substance at all and 59 percent had
amounts of ingredients that were totally
mislabeled so when you start venturing
down that road of supplements that are
like clearly either claiming to be SARS
or like three letters off from the name
of an anabolic compound you you
genuinely have
absolutely no idea what you're gonna get
in that yeah so really your best bet is
just to take snooze I mean your best bet
is probably not to take supplements at
all right but if you do take them look
to make sure that it that it's been
specifically approved by wada
is like there is a testing program like
there are approved manufacturers and
approved supplements out there they're
often times more expensive because they
have to pay for that like certification
process but yeah if you if you really
want to make sure that you're not going
to get popped for unlabeled stuff
because that that is the common claim a
lot of people will make when they do
fail a test if you if that is something
that that you're concerned about make
sure you take stuff that wada has
specifically approved and like Eric said
if you take stuff that they haven't
approved don't throw out the bottle
save it save a few doses so then like if
you have nothing left of the supplements
you took you piss hot and you say oh it
must have been a tainted supplement
they're not going to care during the
appeals process if you can't prove that
it was tainted you know they have
evidence that you had something in your
system and the onus isn't on them to
prove that it was you know anabolics or
stimulants that you were illicitly
taking the onus is on you to prove that
it was something that you didn't think
had those substances that you were
accidentally taking so and one really
key point there is if you can keep at
least a couple doses but also keep the
original bottle yeah because they're
gonna want to look at the lot number
because if you can say hey like let's
say you piss hot for clenbuterol if you
just give them some clenbuterol they're
not gonna be like oh well that's alton
yeah those are like if you give them an
open bottle and have no idea what a lot
number was they might be like how do we
know you didn't spike your supplement
with clenbuterol yeah
for sure so what you what would be ideal
is if you say my extra sample was hot
for that and if you get another unopened
product from that lot number it will
also contain it yeah that's huge
so in powerlifting that's actually what
saved Darrington right about a year ago
or so so Darrington was kind of a rising
star in the u.s. APL he pissed hot I
believe for a banned stimulant and he
said oh it was because you know it must
have been unlabeled on the pre-workout
that I was taking and oftentimes
people's knee-jerk reaction when someone
makes that defense is like yeah sure
like you know you were just trying to
get away with something but yeah he he
did prove his innocence
he did still have the pre-workout he was
taking you sada tested that tested
another like batch of that from the same
lot it also had the banned substance in
it to be clear he did still get a ban
it's like the onus is on you to know
what you're putting in your body so even
if you accidentally take something
that's banned like even if it's an
accident you are still going to serve a
ban but he got his ban reduced from or
he got a suspension reduced from four
years to one because he could prove his
innocence not innocent of having the
drug in his system but innocent of you
know he could show that he wasn't
intentionally taking it there are there
are some some other wild and wacky ways
that someone could contest their
innocence though so the the most common
defenses oh it must have been a tainted
supplement but there are there are some
some other interesting arguments that
people have made before so for example a
couple years ago when the US team was
going over to compete in China for World
Championships and some event I forget
what it was
or you know maybe it was even the
Beijing Olympics I don't remember all of
the details but I remember that either
wada or you sada put out a press release
targeted at the athletes saying don't
eat the pork and they were saying don't
eat the pork because they had tested it
so like I think an athlete had
previously tested positive for
clenbuterol and they said well I didn't
take clenbuterol like maybe they were
just putting it in the animal feed and
everyone was like yeah sure fat chance
they tested the pork that like was being
sold in restaurants and on the street in
China and they found like oh [ __ ] lo and
behold this does actually have enough
clenbuterol still still in the flesh of
these pigs that someone could
theoretically fail a drug test for it so
so that's a possibility and another
another case I heard of and I forget how
this turned out but I've heard people
make similar allegations before so there
was a female either weightlifter
crossfitter I can't remember for sure
but basically her boyfriend was jealous
and thought that she was getting too
close to her male coach and so like he
wanted to get her out of the sport
because he was a jealous [ __ ] and you
know thought that she might be about to
leave him wanted to spend more time with
her whatever and like slipped bandanna
bollocks into like her water bottle and
then when she our food or something like
that and then when she tested positive
she was like oh [ __ ] like I have no idea
how this happened and everyone you know
knee-jerk response was yes or like you
were just trying to beat the test but
then like maybe like a couple weeks
later her boyfriend admitted to it like
yeah like whatever like now you have
evidence you're still going to get
banned for a year or two so now you got
to come back to me and I'm pretty sure
she left his ass
like so but like that that is that is a
possibility as well in there are rumors
of stuff like that happening happening
in track and field as well like yeah
rival countries like trying to sabotage
each other I like trying to slip band
stuff and into the other teams food or
drink so yeah I mean it's it's a wild
and wacky world most of the time appeals
don't go particularly well in just one
final note about drug testing is I often
hear people say that like a drug test is
just an IQ test and it's super easy to
beat drug tests and everyone is doing it
the thing is though I think a lot of
that stems from the fallout of the Lance
Armstrong case and I think what a lot of
people don't realize is drug testing now
is fundamentally different than drug
testing in the 90s or early 2000s so one
is just detection methods have gotten a
lot better so now we have biological
passport so it's not just you know
testing levels of certain substances in
your blood or urine it's establishing a
baseline for an athlete and being able
to more sensitively tell like what is
the typical level of fluctuations of
these metabolites in this particular
athletes blood so before when it was
just like a general range for all
individuals it was a little more lenient
because different people have different
fluctuating levels of hormones and
different metabolites in their system so
the levels at which something would be
considered an adverse analytical finding
were set pretty high just to make sure
that there weren't people who were
outliers that got shafted but biological
passport helps things be more sensitive
for the individual for testing for
androgens and steroids specifically in
primarily here testosterone carbon
isotope ratio testing is huge before
was just based on testosterone - epi
testosterone ratio those tests were
notoriously easy to pass for people with
a decent micro dosing regimen carbon
isotope ratio testing is substantially
more sensitive than those tests were
because it's not just looking at the
levels of testosterone in your blood and
like the ratio of testosterone to some
other hormone it's actually able to tell
whether it was endogenously or
exogenously produced based on carbon
isotope ratios so the cholesterol
backbone that steroid hormones are bell
tone
they have different ratios of carbon-12
and carbon-13 and all of the hormones
that your body produces endogenously are
going to have the same ratio of
carbon-12 to carbon 13 whereas exogenous
hormones you put in your body
mostly manufactured in soy plants I
believe and it just has a different
ratio of carbon-12 to carbon 13 so those
tests are considerably more sensitive
and much much harder to beat and also
just have a longer detection window and
then another thing a lot of people don't
realize is so a common strategy that
people would use to try to take stuff in
beat tests is taking stuff with short
half-lives and then just cycling off
couple weeks out from a competition so
you'd be able to pee clean in
competition so in 2014 the metabolite
tests for a lot of the hormones that
people would rely on for beating tests
so primarily here I'm thinking oral
Torana ball and winstrol those tests got
way way way more sensitive such that
that the detection window went from
being like a week to like two or three
months and so if you were following
weightlifting say in 2014-2015
you probably remember the wave of
athletes that got popped on retests so
there are a couple weight classes from
like the 2008 and 2012 Olympics
we're on retest like the top three or
four finishers in the weight class all
got popped and now like the fourth place
guy has the gold medal or something like
that like it was an absolute [ __ ]
bloodbath and and that was why like
everyone who failed on retest it was
either winstrol or earl or oral turin
appalled because people were using
methods of cycling off that worked in
2008 and 2012 that no longer worked when
the test got better in 2014 and since
wada saved samples for ten years like
they got popped yes they're just a bunch
of really anxious people sitting around
going like well I'll keep an eye on my
phone yeah yeah pretty much and yeah I
think I think the the aspect of wada
drug testing that a lot of people like
fail to appreciate just how good it is
is the fact that they save be samples
for 10 years because like there's the
common trope that like the cheaters are
always ahead of the testers and like
that's probably true like there's there
are probably methods that people are
currently using to beat tests that I
don't know about and that no one
listening to this podcast would know
about like I I'm very open to the idea
that those things are out there but you
know the the question is like a decade's
a long-ass time like is wada going to
figure out about those methods in the
next ten years to then be able to retest
samples and like yeah the ten years is a
long time when it comes to anti-doping
so like you you never you never really
know who did it the right way until ten
years after the fact which is kind of
depressing but but yeah like drug
testing has in the past roughly five
years or
so gotten way way better than it was
during the time when Lance Armstrong was
winning all of his Tour de France's so
it's it a common argument I'll hear is
like Oh like it's so easy to beat these
drug tests just look how many times
Lance Armstrong was tested and got away
with it the drug test that he was going
through are fundamentally different than
the drug test that people go through now
so yeah I just wanted to to put that out
there cuz there there is there is a lot
of ignorance about drug testing and I
think people fail to appreciate how good
modern testing is I think a testament to
that is is the [ __ ] Sochi Olympics you
have Russia which is like notorious for
for beating drug tests and has had a
doping program for a long time they
wanted their athletes to be able to get
an advantage over the competition in the
Sochi Olympics still be able to use
stuff not get popped and like what
strategies do they have to use to beat
the tests well
they didn't rely on biochemists to do it
they relied on FSB agents literally
passing piss cups through a hole in a
wall cut behind a bookshelf I mean
that's I think that's an extreme
testament to just how good modern
anti-doping is like they were doing the
tests in a Russian lab like there in
Russia and the best strategy they can
come up with to beat the test is
literally passing cups of piss through a
hole in a wall so yeah like again just
wanted to get that out there modern
testing is quite good and I think people
fail to appreciate just how much better
it is then then it's battered history
would suggest yeah and so our podcast is
both loved and hated for the heavy dose
of sarcasm that comes with it so on a
serious note I just want to reiterate
you know we don't assert any opinion
about any individual failed drug test we
started the conversation with kind of a
news update on that
but you know he will let that situation
play out you know maybe he has a
successful appeal maybe not who knows
but nonetheless it's a good jumping-off
point for an interesting discussion
about drug testing in general yeah you
know let's uh let's loop back to this
mm-hmm
let's let's hop ahead to the research
roundup because you you have some some
really interesting stuff to discuss here
some very hot takes yeah so have we done
a research roundup yet I don't think we
have so we've done some in detailed
research reviews where we like really
dissect a paper for a while this is
something we call research roundup where
it's it's kind of the Cliff Notes
version if we'd like to see a few
interesting papers that we don't want to
spend ten 15 minutes on it's just a nice
way to kind of give people an update of
some new studies that have hit the press
so I saw a nice little cluster of
studies that came out over the last
month or two and I'd say about a year
ago there was a big lively debate about
overfeeding with really high protein
diets and a lot of people were noticing
based on some studies like oh it looks
like really high amounts of protein
don't seem to be making people
particularly fat they don't seem to be
gaining a lot of fat mass now a lot of
these studies showing this were they had
a great deal of ecological validity they
were free living people and they just
said hey eat a ton of protein but the
problem was they weren't particularly
well controlled and that's kind of the
the give and take in research is the
more you put it into real life the more
you have to sacrifice laboratory
controls so the question was is there
something going on there
if you overfeed protein will you get fat
or on the flip side if you're cutting do
you have to limit your protein or can
you just you know set your protein super
high and be nice and full and happy your
whole diet so that's the question and it
was one of those things where these very
applied studies with free living people
I was just super skeptical the outcomes
because like believe me I've dieted
and I've dieded more than anyone would
want to I'll put it that way and if I
could have been getting away with super
high protein the entire time I feel like
I would have known that I mean there
comes a time in the diet where it's just
the calories have to have to go you know
what I mean you can't just give yourself
unlimited protein so it's just more
importantly academically where is the
energy going you know we're putting it
into the system mm-hmm the question is
unless you have some kind of terrible
malabsorption disorder it's got to go
somewhere you know so there's a few
studies that came out recently that kind
of help shed light on this topic in
general so one is by who how do you
think you pronounce that Greg Suhr
rhythm oh sure I assume it's French it
very French
yeah char riddim ooh we're gonna call it
that oh man I yeah whatever we're filthy
appareance we apologize yeah this
absolute tragic in this pronunciation
but anyway so this paper came out and it
was really cool study they did a
crossover design where they gave pretty
realistic mixed meals since it's French
it's probably just pronounced [ __ ] sure
yeah that sounds good
but they gave mixed meals of varying
macronutrient composition about 500
calorie meals so that those are
realistically sized meals and what this
study showed was evidence that high
protein feeding does induce some degree
of de novo lipogenesis so um you know
this idea that you couldn't like that it
would be literally impossible to gain
fat from protein overfeeding that this
provided some mechanistic insight by
which the pathways are elucidated
another thing they did in the study was
they actually did it like a little
second experiment that was in vitro in
which they identified that they found
evidence in vitro of de novo lipogenesis
with with glutamate glutamine and
leucine but not with lysine so you know
I don't want to die of super deep into
that paper since its Reese
but in any case they make a pretty a
pretty solid case for the idea that
theoretically de novo lipogenesis would
be doable with a high protein intake now
to be clear we're talking about finding
essentially biochemical evidence yeah
what what was what was kind of the
magnitude here like is little minimal
okay yeah okay but in any case you know
a lot of people even with carbohydrate
they say oh it's impossible never
happens but at least it's a thing that
could happen you know a lot of people
say high protein diet knock yourself out
what could possibly go wrong obviously
certain amino acids are gluco genic
others are ketogenic and theoretically
you could be creating some lipid in the
process so again you know that without
getting way down into the weeds on the
details of the study an interesting
finding that pertains to the concept of
protein overfeeding yeah and would
suggest that theoretically especially
over the course of several meals
throughout the day
could it be relevant maybe but what what
they show here are just biochemical
clues that de novo lipogenesis did occur
which is pretty fascinating I think now
the other studies just one other thing
I'll note is for de novo lipogenesis
studies and in primarily here I'm
thinking about the carbohydrate studies
it's it's hard to pick that up if it's
just like cross-sectional work feeding
one meal some of the some of the studies
that have looked at de novo lipogenesis
after carbohydrate feeding find that
with like one meal of massive
carbohydrate over feeding you get
virtually no de novo lipogenesis but
then if you keep fat intake low and keep
carbohydrate intake really high
basically de novo lipogenesis gets
progressively more efficient over time
basically just because it becomes more
required for things to med to function
metabolically the way they should
like you need fatty acids floating
around you don't want crazy high levels
of
glucose in your blood all the time so it
wouldn't shock me if a similar thing
applied to protein where you know maybe
in general you get no or very minimal de
novo lipogenesis from protein
overfeeding but like you said now we
have direct evidence that it is at least
possible yeah and so you know if you had
super low fat intakes and really high
protein intakes it may be that de novo
lipogenesis from protein got more and
more efficient over time yeah yeah again
I I don't think you know the purpose of
bringing up this study is not like guess
what you know that chicken breast you
just had just turned into fat and it's
sitting on your love handles but again
when people talk about these protein
overfeeding studies and you know is it
even possible that they could contribute
to fat gain this is a little extra piece
of evidence kind of elucidating exactly
what can happen to protein when it is
overfed yeah like you you basically you
just you can't treat protein as if it
were calorie free correct and I think
that's the interpretation some people
get from those protein overfeeding
studies yeah definitely now another one
by cassis at all which came out I think
this month Effects of protein quantity
and type on diet-induced thermogenesis
in overweight adults now what this one
showed you know when people talk about
protein overfeeding diet-induced
thermogenesis is is a very important
topic that comes up and what they found
was that the magnitude of diet-induced
thermogenesis did differ based on the
protein dose and the protein type and
we're not talking about like soy versus
way here we're talking about way versus
casein so you know these are fairly
similar proteins that are both
components of of milk so what's really
interesting about this one is that we
think of protein we think okay there's
this very fixed amount of diet-induced
thermogenesis that we can attribute to
it and in reality as we probably should
have figured from the outset it's not
quite that simple
going to depend on the specific type of
protein the dose in which it's given and
the amino acid profile of the protein so
again it further complicates this
question of if we eat a shitload of
protein what happens in where might it
go okay now a third study that came out
and if if I can just make a note on that
I think that I think a lot of people
even folks who do properly respect
science in the scientific process do
become overly fixated on means sometimes
and don't pay adequate attention to
variance so you know I'm sure 90% of the
people listening to this podcast if you
asked like you know what is the relative
thermic effect of feeding for protein
they probably say about 10% but if we
ask like oh and what's what's the
standard deviation there I have no idea
and the thing is like biologies messiest
[ __ ] and like you know if if we're
talking like analytical chemistry or
physics like things are pretty
straightforward like oftentimes you can
calculate exactly what an outcome should
be and if it differs from that or if you
have standard deviations it's probably
just because of experimental error or
measurement error or something like that
that's not the case in biology like
things are highly variable and it's
important to note the degree of
variability you're talking about so you
know 10% plus or minus 1% yeah you can
probably just treat that as 10% 10% plus
or minus 7%
that's a fundamentally different thing
you're dealing with then it's less of
okay here is a fact that I can learn
it's 10% that is what it is and it moves
it more into well this may be something
I need to troubleshoot because it could
be twenty percent could be zero percent
definitely and that's actually a really
good segue into the third study the
third recent study on this topic that I
kind of clustered together here
this one was Johansson at all and what
they were looking at is over feeding
over an eight week period and the title
of the paper is metabolic adaptation is
not observed after eight weeks of over
feeding but energy expenditure
variability is associated with weight
recovery and so what they found was even
though when they talk metabolic
adaptation here they're talking about an
increase in metabolic rate in response
to over feeding and what they found was
that as a whole in the group there was
not a pronounced effect but in some
individuals metabolic rate and energy
expenditure did go up quite a bit in
response to over feeding and those were
the people that in the washout period
after the over feeding reverted back to
normal body weight the people who did
not have a market increase in energy
expenditure tended to retain the the fat
that they gained in the over feeding
period and so this kind of goes along
very nicely with a whole body of
literature a small body but a body
nonetheless showing that the responses
to over feeding are very variable
between people some people when you over
feed them they have a huge increase in
metabolic rate their physical activity
level their non exercise even
subconscious activity level goes up
quite a bit and their appetite
disappears these are people that defend
their body weight very well in response
to over feeding and so like there's that
easy thing that as a practitioner you
always lean on where you say well
everybody's different but no like there
are variables that have a ton of
variance I mean it's it's quantifiable
that responses are quite different
within populations and so to me the
question was always when we see these
very applied relatively loosely
controlled studies with protein over
feeding and they're not gaining weight
or fat mostly they're not gaining fat
the question is will not you know the
question is basically what could be
happening when you over feed somebody
with excess calories from protein we've
always known that sure the energy could
be
used we could be converting these amino
acids to to you know a glucose related
molecule or a ketone now there's
evidence that theoretically we could
make some fad via de novo lipogenesis I
think depending on the type of protein
and the doses of protein some of it
might essentially be vanishing due to
diet induced thermogenesis and then for
some people in response to the
overfeeding they might be compensating
via body increased metabolic rate
increased activity level and they could
be under eating their prescribed
allotment just a little bit because a
lot of people when they're overfed
especially with high protein their
appetite disappears so they might be
saying oh yeah I definitely got all that
food in and I would suspect some of them
metaphorically have their thumb on the
scale yeah that'll do yeah so it's just
a cluster of studies that to someone may
not look particularly related but to me
it they collectively kind of helped
approximate a bit of a what's the word
I'm thinking of a bit of a paradox full
frontal assault on the dogma of being
able to eat unlimited amounts of protein
exactly got across the bow a full-on
siege complete with multiple trebuchet
which are superior to catapults and
other siege engines in every conceivable
way thank you for contributing Greg what
I was going to say is a paradoxical
finding in which overeating apparently
didn't seem to do what we always expect
it to do and so these help kind of fill
in some of those gaps we can go with
that too yeah okay now another way way
way briefer research roundup I've just
got a little grouping of two studies
that came out this month now if you're
an OG and you've been listening to us
from day one the first episode we had
Peter Fitch and on for our interview and
we talked a little bit about hmb because
he had done some
Jambi research back in the day two
studies this month one by Trudeau a tall
one by tech Sierra at all
I believe that's Teixeira Teixeira at
all I've only left the United States two
times Greg I mean do you watch baseball
not I don't watch anything man okay
I don't watch anything there was there
was a very good baseball I remember play
for the A's for awhile I think maybe
late career okay Rangers I think he
played for the twins alright well we'll
look it up okay we'll put in the show
now but but but no so two studies came
out no no need to give a a lot of timer
attention to them but they basically
both looked at all sorts of forms and
permutations and combinations of hmb
with training to see how they affect
hypertrophy and not much man not much so
if you were one of these skeptics who
saw enormous changes in in strength and
muscle mass in response to hmb and you
thought hey that looks strange there's
there's a lot more evidence coming out
showing that yeah that's not that's not
typical just as a fact check mark
Teixera played for the Texas Rangers
Lana Braves Los Angeles Angels of
Anaheim and the New York Yankees I got
the Rangers you did nice okay one more
study that we want to spend a little
extra time on not as part of the roundup
it is called FD steroids as
non-conventional anabolic agents
performance enhancement by FD stare own
supplements in humans so let me pull up
the old paper here so we can really do
it justice this is by Eisenman at all
and it was published I think it came out
this month right yeah it came out like
last week which by the time you're
listening to this is probably like four
months ago
let's do we're gonna get it up in like
ten days I know I know it's just
this is currently breaking news and by
the time by the time it gets up the news
cycle will have probably moved on but we
we can present it as we're the ones who
took a couple weeks to actually look
into this gather all of the facts
investigative journalism when it's
actually you know this is still just
like two days after it came out these
are actually just our hot takes but you
will get our hot takes two weeks late
that's right so Greg do you want to give
a brief overview of the the setup here
yeah so um in this study they gave they
gave people a supplement that was
labeled to have a hundred milligrams of
do you pronounce the D is it a hard D or
a softie is it FD stare own or ecchi
stare own I think you pronounce it but
I've mispronounced like seven or eight
words this podcast yeah so we're going
with the hard D on this one let's do it
so they gave them a pill or they gave
them pills that were labeled to have a
hundred milligrams of FD starin and a
hundred milligrams of leucine and we can
completely disregard the leucine because
a hundred milligrams of leucine is
absolutely nothing or a control and
there were two groups who were given the
supplement one group was given a low
dose which was two pills per day and the
other group was given a high dose which
I believe was six pills per day either
five or six so you know both getting a
both getting a look at does the
supplement do what it claims to do and
is there a dose response relationship
here they assess strength they assess
body comp they had people you know
undergo a training program
longitudinally for I believe ten weeks
and they were you know basically looking
to see does this supplement do anything
the reason they were looking at this
just as some background is ecchi stare
if you're wondering what XD means has a
prefix that just means insect so exci
stare own is a molting hormone for
insects
so as insects grow they molt similar to
the same way like a snake would and so
essentially these are just hormones
implicated in the growth and development
of insects similar to the way that human
sex hormones are implicated in the
growth and development of humans and so
they're structurally somewhat similar to
to mammalian steroids and in some in
vitro research there so there there's
some in vitro research I believe on
mouse muscle fibers indicating that FD
starin does pretty substantially
increased muscle protein synthesis so
that that's kind of the background of
why someone might expect this to work so
that's why they were testing it and like
I said longitudinal training study
placebo control two different doses of
the supplement and what did they find
the stats on a study where the groups
have like ten people I'm just gonna I'm
just gonna go off-road with it here go
off-script I'm looking at charts
okay so findings change in body weight
after this supplementation with training
the placebo group gained about a
kilogram the the low-dose group about
two and a half and the high dose group
about three the muscle mass the placebo
group actually went down a little bit
the low dose and the higher dose
increased by about one point five and
two kilograms respectively everybody
increased their back squat by you know
the placebo about 16% 18% for low dose
and about nineteen for the high dose so
very very similar I'm sorry those squad
numbers were kilograms not percentages
event benchpress placebo up by about
three kilograms the low dose up by
almost ten and the high dose up by about
eight kilograms
bench press so generally speaking what
they found was that the supplement
appeared to be effective for the the
performance outcomes they had some other
performance outcomes in addition to
those also appeared to be effective for
increase in body weight and muscle mass
now probably the most notable finding
was that the supplement didn't really
contain much at all of the active
ingredient
yeah and that's I believe that's the
kicker here that is the big-time kicker
so it was supposed to have what was it a
hundred 100 milligrams 100 milligrams
per dose and what did they find per per
dose was it like six well sick it was
six yeah so when you're coming in at six
percent of a labelled value that's not
that's not great no because like to
contextualize that when I see a study on
a supplement and I in it it is
surprisingly looks effective something I
didn't expect to be particularly
effective my first thought is oh boy
here we go
you know the the old company slipped
them some cash under the table I've seen
this one before
yeah dude like the company is probably
not stoked like it's like so basically
like the real the really trick and I
mean it could have been a labeling
mishap so I this the the Act II stare on
that they got was an extraction from
spinach something that surprises a lot
of people which i think is pretty
interesting is spinach actually has a
reasonably high level of acne steroids
in it that just kind of like illustrates
the the amount of overlap in genetics
stuff between kind of all forms of life
on Earth I don't know what biological
role acne steroids play in the growth
and development of spinach but yeah
there's there's a reasonably high amount
in in spinach and also in a fungus
called Rippon tucum so oftentimes if
someone did want to take acne steroid
supplements it would either be a
répondre
extract or a spinach extract and so what
it very well could have been was they
gave them a hundred milligrams of
spinach extract which had six milligrams
of acne starin but it was still
mislabeled because it said a hundred
milligrams of acne stare own not a
hundred milligrams of spinach extract
right and now the question is have they
done other human studies looking at
similar outcomes like this I believe
this is the first one so we can't even
say like hey can we expect six
milligrams to be an efficacious dose
because we don't have yeah so here's
here's here's where I get sceptical so
first things first I have not seen I've
not seen pharmacokinetic studies in
humans looking at like rate of
appearance and blood and how quickly
like what the half-life of the
supplement in in serum is but at least
in rodent studies it seems like it has a
half-life of like 10-15 minutes so even
accounting for the fact that human
metabolisms just run slower than rodent
metabolisms and maybe there's a slightly
longer half-life in humans I'm skeptical
that this stuff would even stay in your
system long enough to have much of an
effect like when you take steroids even
steroids with relatively short
half-lives for the most part you know a
dose of something a reasonable amount is
is going to be in your system for at
least a day or two and for this we may
be talking minutes two hours so one I'm
skeptical that it stays in your system
long enough to do much and then two for
it to the the thing that makes me
skeptical is the low dose group here so
with the high dose group they were
taking again like five or six pills and
it's you know 30 36 milligrams of stuff
if we use traditional anabolic oral
antibiotic agents that someone may take
as a point of comparison you know 30 35
milligrams of something like d ball or
winstrol
per day that's a reasonably low dose but
like that is a dose that would probably
do something 12 milligrams per day like
that's that's nothing so looking back at
the history of steroid research until
like the mid 90s the take in the
scientific community was like oh all of
these athletes are trying to use
steroids but what do you know steroids
don't actually do anything and the
reason people came to that conclusion is
if you go back and read those old
studies for the most part they were
putting people on like 10 milligrams of
d-ball a day and like bball works we
know d-ball works but like 10 milligrams
a day isn't enough for it to do much so
we if if we do accept that acne stirone
is like if we accept that it works we
then also have to assume that since we
did see some results with the low dose
as well we have to assume it works even
better than the oral antibiotics that
most people would take and we also have
to assume there's not really a dose
response relationship here because the
the wait changes were fairly small in
every group the squat findings were
pretty similar in every group and it
didn't really seem like it helped the
squat that much and then the bench
findings you know the the low dose group
did just as well as the high dose group
they actually did a little better I
think yeah so we would we would be stuck
having to make the assumption that you
know at low doses
this shit's way better than the oral
antibiotics that people take but there's
no dose response relationship like you
plateau at a super low dose and I just
find that to be really implausible
assumptions that someone would have to
take on board to actually make sense of
these findings now what the authors
themselves say in the conclusion is our
results strongly suggest including ectis
darrone in class s1 anabolic agents so
they're there they're going with the
idea
like this is some potent stuff that
needs to be managed and they speculate
that the mechanism of action pertains to
binding to the estrogen receptor beta so
they're throwing out a mechanism that
they're saying hey this is a potent
anabolic that needs that warrants
attention of anti-doping agencies I
think you and I have concerns that
certainly pertain to sample size yeah
that's a pretty hot conclusion to draw
from a study with a sample this small
yes and and just to be clear I'm not
[ __ ] on small sample research right
now because I mean longitudinal training
studies are a [ __ ] pain in the ass to
carry out like we we both have
first-hand experience ated so so yeah
like I'm not hating on that like you
know small sample research is what it is
but you probably shouldn't draw that
strong of a conclusion from a small
sample study like this it's risky and
you know there's all sorts of cool
visualizations that show you how wonky
something like a correlation can be if
you just consecutively draw ten person
samples from a population of a thousand
or 10,000 like the relationships that
form and disappear just due to sampling
error are pretty remarkable like you
should go go find the jiff of it because
it's really I just included it in a
presentation down to Mexico and it was
people were looking at it like they
couldn't believe that all these samples
were coming from the same population
data so yeah anytime you have small
sample research again like this is one
of those cool instances where the
results are difficult to wrap your head
around but you don't actually believe
anybody's messing with you you know what
I mean like yeah yeah so yet to be clear
we're not accusing the researchers of
anything untoward no not at all
because it wouldn't make sense if you
were gonna if you're gonna do something
yeah it wouldn't look like this okay I
think they did everything by you you
know I mean they did it the way it's
supposed to be done it's just weird
things can happen
yeah we're animals we're left with one
two explanations of this either one and
low doses this stuff works way better
than pretty much any supplement or
anabolic agent that we're aware of but
it has no dose response relationship
such that taking more of it doesn't
actually help get you better results
which like that's just walkie or we're
seeing false positives from small sample
research which happens all the time
and for me evaluating those two possible
explanations of the results you know I
think just false positives are
considerably more likely than the the
assumptions we'd have to make about the
potency and lack of dose response
relationship to take the results at face
value yeah and there there is some you
know the in everything except the bench
press
generally speaking the high dose group
did a little better than the low dose
but but it was not a traditional like
linear dose-response like you would
expect yeah another thing that should be
kept in mind especially when it comes to
the estimations of muscle mass is the
body composition was measured using
single frequency bio impedance analysis
now BIA and bis in general have some
pretty serious limitations they're
basically using electrical current to
make an estimate about some type of body
water whether it's intracellular
extracellular or total body water and
then making assumptions about how that
amount of body water relates to fat mass
and lean mass it assumes that the body
is a series of perfect cylinders which
it is not it's actually a series of
tubes exactly a series of tubes there
are all sorts of assumptions baked into
that cake that you have to be very
generous in giving the equipment it
doesn't make it useless but there's
important limitations to consider and
the fact that it's single frequency you
know nowadays there are multi frequency
devices that are
even substantially better than the
single ones so you know the reason
that's important is because at a single
frequency you're kind of stuck with
whatever that frequency current can
penetrate whereas if you use a spectrum
of frequencies like in bio impedance
spectroscopy you can send currents that
are you know have no ability to to you
know go through cell barriers or cell
walls and then as the frequency changes
there are different there's differing
abilities to penetrate different
structures as it flows through the
system so when you do multi frequency
and a spectrum of frequencies it allows
you to make a much more thorough
estimate when it comes to evaluating
intracellular fluid extracellular total
body water and then you can use that to
make a slightly more informed estimate
of lean mass and fat mass so perhaps I'm
just drinking the multi frequency
kool-aid but to me it sounds like a much
even just theoretically the rationale
sounds a lot better to me yeah so I
guess to wrap things up it's like I feel
like multi frequency bis kool-aid is a
variety of kool-aid that most people
listening to this weren't even aware
existed it is it is a very specialized
form of kool-aid out there when you when
you hit the like the medical device
sales conference circuit there's a lot
of people drinking that kool-aid uh but
I bet but maybe not in the fitness
community so just a recap it's really
interesting it's a cool study I'm hoping
that this will encourage other research
groups to follow up and say hey what's
up with this ingredient and maybe
there's something to it but when you
have limitations such as a very small
sample size per group and the type of
device used for body comp you have to be
very cautious when interpreting it so
again we don't it's really no fault of
the researchers that's just the name of
the game and that's why we always say
hey
more researchers needed yeah just just
for the time being I know I'm quite
skeptical and I think you are as well
just don't don't rush to strong
conclusions from one single study yeah
and that that goes always a single study
especially when the samples you know
smaller than your family
you probably shouldn't take it too far
with your interpretation yeah okay so
Greg you on Monday you posted a new
article to the website all about
squatting do you mind telling us about
your new article yeah so if you've been
following chong'er by science for a
while you know that for a few years I
had like a new article about squatting
maybe once every month or two we
published a very thorough squat guide in
2016 and since then like that guide has
held up pretty well to the point that I
just haven't really felt the need to say
anything else or update things all that
much but recently a study was published
from Kubo a tall titled effects of squat
training with different depths on lower
limb muscle volumes and I wanted to
review this study because it it provided
more solid more solid results for two of
the things that I've been saying about
squatting for a while
based on like cross-sectional research
or or more theory that didn't quite have
solid results to back them up yet so
yeah this this gave me more like solid
longitudinal findings to to base those
opinions on so in this study they had
two groups of people one group was doing
full squats so through 140 degrees of
knee range of motion the other group was
doing half squats which was through 90
degrees of knee range of motion they had
them trained for a while and the the
main thing this study was interested in
is the effects of school
depth the main thing I was interested in
is the effects on hypertrophy of
different muscle groups of the lower
body in the full squat group so the the
article itself also talks about depth
somewhat but I mostly you just want to
go over the hypertrophy findings in in
this little bit on the podcast since
we've already gone pretty long so
essentially they looked at hypertrophy
in the quads in the adductors in the
gluteus maximus and in the hamstrings
and long story short quads grew a bunch
adductors grew a bunch glute max grew a
bunch hamstrings basically didn't grow
at all the average increase was like a
half a percent increase and so the
reason that this interested me is one I
have been preaching the gospel of the
adductors being the primary hip
extensors in the squat sins like 2015 to
this point the strongest evidence that
that was the case was one just basic
biomechanical reasoning the adductor the
adductor Magnus I believe is the second
largest muscle in the body by cross
sectional area and it has a very
favorable internal moment arm for a hip
extension when the hips are in deep
flexion as they would be in the bottom
of a squat and they're a mono articular
muscle so with the hamstrings they also
have a very favorable moment arm for hip
extension in the bottom of a squat but
when the hamstrings contract that
produces a knee flexion moment so
they're kind of countering what the
quads are trying to do glutes also a
very big very strong muscle have a very
very unfavorable internal moment arm for
hip extension when you're in deep hip
flexion as you would be in the bottom of
a squat so from that you can just kind
of logically infer that the adductor
Magnus is probably going to be the most
important hip extensors to get out of
the hole in a squat
there was some modeling research by
Vygotsky and bryant in' that supported
that but virtually every squat paper out
there that has looked at like
longitudinal effects on hypertrophy has
only looked at the quads and a couple
have looked at the hamstrings as well
the adductor the the abductors and
specifically the adductor Magnus just
get completely overlooked so you know
there was some reasoning for me thinking
that it was probably the the dominant
hip extensors in the squat but no actual
experimental evidence to fall back on
now in this study we see very very
robust hypertrophy of the abductors in
people doing deep squats that doesn't
necessarily prove the full extent of my
position that they're probably the most
important hip extensors in the squat but
it does at least give us very very solid
evidence that they are heavily involved
in the squat and that the squat does
good work at targeting the adductors and
causing robust hypertrophy in them
another thing I thought was interesting
was the amount of glute hypertrophy seen
in this study so there's so so that may
not surprise a lot of people it didn't
necessarily surprise me but one thing to
note is there was kind of a split in
people who like follow the biomechanics
literature about the degree to which
squats targeted the gluteus maximus the
reason for that is the glutes are really
really active in full hip extension
really really strong in full hip
extension not all of that active in deep
hip flexion and also like I already said
have an utter asked here internal moment
arm pun intended for being able to
produce hip extension torque in deep hip
flexion as you would be in the bottom of
a squat so that could lead one to
surmise that the squats aren't actually
able to train the glutes all that hard
because the most challenging portion of
the squat is when you are in deep hip
flexion when the glutes simply aren't
able to contribute all that much and
aren't all that active so the position
that the squats do target the glutes a
fair amount is one like you know there
is more to the squat than the whole once
you get out of the hole you got to get
through the sticking point and then -
even if the hardest parts of the squat
aren't when the glutes have the most
favorable internal moment arm you still
have to produce something approaching
maximal hip extension torque to stand up
out of the hole with a really really
heavy squat the glutes are another you
know very strong kumano articular hip
extensors it's like of course they have
to contribute to some degree and one of
the things we see in some EMG research
is that you get a spike in glute
activation around the midway point
during the concentric of the lift which
roughly corresponds to the sticking
point so what's probably going on there
is yeah the glutes aren't really doing
all that much to help you out of the
hole but then when you do hit the
sticking point the mid-range of the lift
they really kick on in a big way to help
you clear that sticking point and as
such the squat does become a an
effective exercise for training the
glutes and glute hypertrophy which again
I think that's what most people probably
expected that's what I expected but
there was a counter position to that and
to this point there hadn't been any
longitudinal research with the squat
actually measuring glute hypertrophy
after squat training so this does give
us solid longitudinal evidence that yes
squats are doing a pretty good job of
training the glutes and then the last
thing to note is very very little
hamstrings hypertrophy and one of the
things I've been arguing for years now
is that like yeah like obviously your
hamstrings are involved in the squat to
some degree but at least when I got into
powerlifting the common position was
that the hamstrings
the most important hip extensors in the
squat I think a lot of that was based on
the amount of focus louis simmons put on
the hamstrings specifically talking
about how in a box squat you want to sit
super super far back so that the box
squat essentially becomes a hamstring
curl to train the hamstrings because
they're the main hip extensors in the
squat like i think that was the basic
line of reasoning there but like i
looked at that and i was like no like
that that can't be the case because
essentially you have multiple strong hip
extensors you have multiple strong mono
articular hip extensors in the adductor
magnus and the glutes they produce a lot
of hip extension torque don't produce a
knee flexion torque they're not trying
to resist what the quads are doing
hamstrings also very strong can produce
a lot of hip extension torque but they
do also produce knee flexion torque so
they're countering what the quads are
trying to accomplish and like obviously
a squat is also hard for your quads so
just purely from a problem-solving
perspective it wouldn't make sense for
your nervous system to lean super hard
on your hamstrings when you have other
hip extensors that can do the job and
there is also like there's research in
general on mounting articular versus by
articular muscle activation in compound
exercises and in general what we see is
that you don't get that much out of by
articular muscles until mono articular
muscles can no longer do the job so
they're kind of contracting
isometrically to stabilize things
transfer force to different segments but
art prime movers we say we see the same
thing with the quads as well so the
vastus lateralis medialis intermedius
very active in the squat hypertrophy a
lot after squat training the rectus
femoris which is another by articular
muscle helps extend the knee also exerts
hip flexion torque which is not what you
wanted to squat rectus femoris
activation way way lower in the squat
then say a knee extension and you don't
see as much rectus femoris hypertrophy
after squat training as you do
vas ty high perch
so yeah just from a like neuro
mechanical perspective and just kind of
thinking through the movement one would
not expect the squat to train the
hamstrings particularly hard certainly
not as hard as the other hip extensors
but to this point I had mostly like
argued from that like rationality
perspective but this study did actually
measure longitudinal change in hamstring
hamstring muscle volume I dug back
through some of the articles I
previously cited in in squat articles
like this there were two others one by
Bloomquist and colleagues and one by
Weiss which did also measure both quad
and hamstring hypertrophy after squat
training and essentially like all three
of the studies really show either non
significant or pretty minimal hamstrings
hypertrophy after squat training so it's
not just like this one study is a rare
outlier so yeah like I feel like I feel
like it sometimes comes across as if I
have a vendetta against the hamstrings
like hamstrings are awesome I just want
to make sure that when people are
focusing on like what should I be
feeling in the squat and what like what
training effects should I expect to get
from the squat you know expect it to be
great for your quads and expect to feel
it in your quads expect it to be great
for your adductors expect to feel it in
your adductors when we publish the
article most people commented like well
no [ __ ] squats are an adductor exercise
like that's the thing that gets the most
[ __ ] up every time I squat and expect
it to be a pretty good exercise for your
glutes as well the reason that I harp so
much on squats not being a particularly
effective exercise for the hamstrings is
I see a lot of strength athletes who do
way more squat training than deadlift
training which is understandable a lot
of people do recover better from squats
than from deadlifts
so just kind of from an ROI perspective
for your total may make a little more
sense to lean into squat training but I
do think that a lot of lifters would
specifically benefit from additional
hamstrings training like doing good
mornings or rdls specifically because so
much of our lower body training
typically comes from squats and squats
are having a training effect on your
hamstrings but not nearly to the same
degree as your quads and other hip
extensors so like that's that's the main
reason I harp on the hamstrings lack of
involvement in the squat so much because
like I want to be able to give people
good guidance about like what other
things do do you need to focus on in
your training beyond just you know
relying on squats for lower body
training yeah I mean I remember that you
were talking about the the squat not
being a hamstrings exercise fan I mean
it was like before we were even really
friends like we didn't even hang out
back then it's been a while but yet on
that did people initially give you a lot
of [ __ ] for that umm do you get a lot of
like kickback or like fighting against
that idea so so what I'll say is that
one I get a lot less negative feedback
now than I used to and also the ratio of
positive to negative feedback has always
been skewed towards positive but the
people who respond negatively to that
respond very vocally and very negatively
so it's it's a topic that I haven't
touched on for a few years just because
it's always such a big [ __ ] headache
every time I do so so the median
response is positive but the mean is
closer to closer to neutral discus yeah
there there's there's a lot of like
milquetoast positive responses and then
a handful of like nuclear negative
responses militant hamstring activists
yeah and it's like it's like dude if I'm
wrong show me evidence that I'm wrong
and the thing is like something we
touched on earlier is like yeah for
pretty much anything in biology like
there's a there's a lot of variance
between people and so I think some folks
like they do feel their hamstrings a lot
in the squat and like I'm not gonna call
them liars
like I'm not making a claim that no one
is hamstring reliant in the squat like
that would be a ludicrous claim to make
but like your normative external
experience is not a normative experience
like if squats really train your
hamstrings hard like that's awesome but
it's also a typical which is which is
fine it's just like you know if you want
to make the claim that squats are
generally a good and very effective
hamstring exercise for people show me
the evidence like your your anecdote
very strong evidence for you personally
not very strong evidence for making a
general claim and if you want to read
more about this topic as we mentioned
that what that article is free on the
website you remember the exact title so
people can search it yeah it's a dumb
title its squats are secretly an
adductor exercise it's effective but it
talks about the adductors talks about
the glutes talks about the hamstrings
talks a lot about squat depth which I
didn't really mention here um so yeah
like I just hate thinking of article
titles and yeah simple ones get the job
done absolutely so we will also link
that in the description of this podcast
now we are at a time for this week's
episode so to play us out we began the
episode with a controversy Ludacris
allegations that we were not the first
fitness podcast we put those to bed now
I want to put another nasty rumor to bed
a lot of people have been kind of
indicating that Greg is the co-host of
this podcast and I just want to be
really clear as I am every week Greg is
not a co-host in this podcast he is a a
temporary assistant to the host and he's
I will I will admit he has been on many
of the previous episodes and we
currently have future episodes in the
works where he will also be a guest
so but I just want to nip that in the
bud he is not a co-host as my show but
I'm happy to have him sometimes anything
you add to that Greg no not really but
you do confirm
yeah for sure okay hey I just don't want
to I don't want this to come up again so
I want this on record I don't see how
someone could I don't see how someone
could think otherwise like why why would
someone listen to this podcast and think
that we were co-hosts that it's baffling
to me I don't know I mean we got people
who don't get the still don't even
understand that we dislike Eric Helms
they can't even get that from ya so you
can't get through to some people
speaking of which we got a great
interview with Eric Helms it was tense
it was contentious but we had a lot of
fun because we came out on top so at the
on the other side of the music enjoy the
interview with dr. Eric Helms
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the stronger by science
podcast this is eric Trexler and Greg
knuckles of stronger by science and for
the interview portion of today's episode
we are joined by the good dr. Eric Helms
Eric thanks for coming on my pleasure
dr. Eric Trexler it's just a couple
doctors having a good chat and Greg and
you and this guy over here with a beard
Greg knuckles as everyone knows the
intellectual lightweight mm-hmm Eric if
people don't know who you are could you
give us like a very brief explanation of
who you are and what you're about sure
absolutely first just big thanks for
having me on guys it's always a pleasure
and yeah I'm just a dude who really
loves lifting weights and loves the the
culture the science the history the
experience in the community and is doing
my best to give back to it so I began
lifting back in G's 2004 and it very
much became my sole focus of life it
came at a time where I needed some kind
of outlet so it kind of served that role
emotionally for me which got me
connected to it and then became a
personal trainer cuz I wanted to pursue
it as a career did that for four or five
years or so before starting 3d muscle
journey with the rest of the crew then
it became very focused on working with
body builders and power lifters started
competing myself in drug-free
bodybuilding in powerlifting in oh six
and powerlifting I was seven for
bodybuilding and then just pursued my
academics and if we fast forward all
that to 2019 I finished my PhD couple
years back and I'm now working as a
research fellow at a sports performance
Research Institute in New Zealand here
in Auckland New Zealand where I have
PhDs and master's students and I
facilitate our SSC group meetings on a
regular basis so I'm doing a lot of
mentoring and and hosting of research
which is a lot of fun still doing the 3d
MJ thing I'm the R&D head there and I'm
loving doing mass with Greg knuckles and
also dr. Mike sardos got a
books and in general and it's doing the
science communication thing and I still
compete so so Eric you uh you mentioned
something called mass now for people
unaware of that could you just fill us
in on what it is and maybe give like a
quick five to ten minute sales pitch
well men correct if you haven't heard of
monthly applications and strikes for it
you are missing out it is the gold
standard industry preferred personal
training strength conditioning coach
bodybuilding coach or athlete resource
for the serious evidence-based
professional and in the low price of
$29.99 per month you can read articles
by Gregg knuckles dr. Mike Sir dose dr.
Eric Helms and watching videos of those
two as well with guest contributions on
a regular basis back now man that that
is absolutely tremendous and sounds like
something that everyone should check out
and buy right now well I agree Gregg and
thanks for having me on the podcast and
I'll see you guys next time I ever since
I started working with stronger by
science I've had a million people ask me
how are things going with mass and no
one asked me how are things going with
stronger by science well you know a
funny story and I don't remember if you
were with me a lot what was happening
but when we were both in Finland Eric
one of the the Finnish researchers asked
me and it could have been an English
thing but I'd like to think it's not as
hilarious ask me how it was to work for
Greg because now I work for stronger by
science and Greg knuckles because we do
math together and I was like he's a
great boss you know we have company
retreats
he only yells at me sometimes you know
it's good so yeah he's been good to my
family yes very much
I think at the end of the day it's kind
of like a puppet master thing if you
work in Fitness we all kind of work for
Greg knuckles in a roundabout way yes he
is the man behind the curtain with most
things including the academic
infrastructure of sports science mm-hmm
yes so I would agree he assumes all all
blame for anything that's bad and all
credit for anything
good yeah it's a lofty position I don't
envy him but someone has to be the blame
for everything so in am I just like the
bilderbergs in this in this situation
the dark cabal behind the scenes pretty
much yeah cool either you're the
freemasons you're you're the
Rockefellers you are you're the ghost in
the machine
you are the machine you're not even a
ghost in the machine you're the machine
and I feel like I want to rage against
you okay I mean I can work with that
so we've already contributed a lot of
really good content here but I I want to
move things at a different direction now
you mentioned us in Finland as an you
mean a direction basically yeah and
anything resembling a direction
you mentioned Finland and when we were
in Finland we talked a little bit about
contest prep as to body about body
builders would you're currently in a
prep right I am I'm actually three weeks
out as of today awesome so I want to ask
you a few questions about your prep I
don't want to do the generic like Eric
Helms welcome to the podcast how much
protein should I eat so I want to ask
you some more applied questions
especially because we got you in a
pretty unique time window for a
bodybuilder yeah so this prep you know
I've noticed every time I prep I do
things a little differently have you
done anything differently this prep
compared to what you typically have done
in the past yeah I mean I've actually
done a lot differently this prep and a
lot of it comes down to the attitude the
motivation behind it and the methodology
of ensuring I'm actually in a deficit
losing fat and making progress and it's
largely that I'm using a lot more
qualitative indicators and I'm being
less I would say less structured but I'm
being less rigid in the way I use
numbers and targets are you tracking
your macros on a daily basis at this
point but actually I should say no
because I'm largely focusing on protein
and calories for the most part but I
have only started having specific tar
it's that I'm trying to hit for calories
in the last two weeks so starting around
five weeks out and that was partially
just to feel like I am being at the low
of calories I need to be on the low days
just because as you deal with a smaller
number which I unfortunately do deal
with small numbers on my load days as I
get leaner and leaner
small deviations end up being large
proportional deviations if that makes
sense just mathematically and also I
think Berto
is kind of guiding me into this he's
taking a little more of a firmer role
now that we're down to the kind of the
final little bit of details that need to
come in so I think he wants to make sure
that when he's looking at changes in my
body he can associate them better with
with specific quantitative changes so he
can do things like peakmi appropriately
or decide how long and how hard we
should push given how much we have left
in our time frame so yeah for the first
I guess it was 10 weeks it was based on
how hungry I thought I should be how
lethargic I thought I should be my
performance my rate of weight loss on
the scale visually what I was seeing in
life you know so if things came up where
my wife asked me to eat out I would
think alright well how does it affect
the rest of the week for needing to be
in the appropriate deficit or surplus
how would I restructure you know our
eating habits and when are we planning
on cooking versus not and what do I need
to do to still achieve the appropriate
weight of weight loss while doing that
so so so you're living during prep
exactly how you're doing both at the
same time I think that's very well set
and you know just to give you an idea of
how much of life is going on at this
time in the last five weeks I've had
four PhD students arrive from which is
which is a big deal when they're doing
it you know moving across a couple of
states in the US but I'm talking about a
couple from Croatia who came to New
Zealand I'm talking about gentleman from
Florida who came here and I'm talking
about a gentleman from Malaysia who have
moved their entire lives and in two
cases it stayed with me for a week in
our guest room I showed him around and
got him set up with a bank you know
their phone and really trying to you
know ease the transition as an immigrant
to it to a new country and get him set
up as a student at aut
wait is it is it Kendrick yeah Kendrick
Kendrick Quan is here
Colby Scioscia is here yeah yeah they're
all out here man and also Ivan Juke itch
and his partner who is also gonna be
doing a PhD with me Katharina burns AK
so I've got a stable of five PhD
students physically located here now and
we're doing some cool stuff yeah it's a
lot of fun it's a lot of fun and
literally just as of a week ago my mom
actually moved out here and she's
currently staying with us while we do
some apartment hunting you know try to
get her set up with you know a car and
transportation all that stuff and you
know I traveled to Australia a few weeks
back and I did the first annual sports
nutrition Australia a conference with
like Shaun Aaron was out there and it
was you know they're basically an
affiliate of ISSN but in Australia and
being able just to do that Walt while
prepping is something I don't think I
would have envisioned even in my more
flexible years and you know 2011 was my
last prep and I think I did a really
good job but probably couldn't have done
this this new approach we kind of talked
about that in Finland I remember we were
talking bodybuilding and I mentioned
like in my most recent prep I didn't
feel like dealing with the numbers
day-to-day no I kind of took a more
qualitative approach and the only thing
I was really weighing was my protein
sources to make sure I was hitting my
protein target yeah and I remember being
embarrassed to tell you that because I
was like well I tell you what Eric
here's a stupid thing I do but um but
like for me I enjoyed it a lot I mean
has that been it next time through do
you see yourself taking a similar
approach or do you think you'll go back
to a more numbers driven approach
well you know and we talked about this
in Finland as well and I definitely
didn't think it was it was stupid or
anything you should have been
embarrassed about but I understand why
you were that way of us being not only
bodybuilders but bodybuilders in like
the super nerdy you know evidence-based
little clique of it where you know
macros and then period ization and
spreadsheets are are just as much part
of the the ethos of our identity as like
hard work and the other things that are
traditionally a bodybuilder right so it
at that point when we were in Finland I
guess that when was that that was a
October's been like October yeah yeah I
was thinking like alright how am I gonna
do this thing
and I knew that I wanted to incorporate
some of the habit based and more
qualitative stuff that I've been
academically interested in and
experimenting with during my mini cuts
that it worked really well but part of
me was kind of like I well you can't do
that for prep and the discussion we had
kind of tipped the scales for me a
little bit if I'm honest and I was like
all right you know what let's let's be
an adult adult about this and see what
you can do so I think that was a really
valuable conversation and the thing
about it being qualitative versus
quantitative I almost feel like that's
in an experienced bodybuilder it's not a
it's not a fair it's almost like a false
comparison because I can't not know what
my my macros calories and protein
roughly are right like at this stage of
having been coaching and and tracking
that stuff on my own on and off for four
G's over a decade like if you just ask
me how many grams of protein of you
today I'll tell you and I know that I'm
probably no more than 10% off tops and
same thing with calories so it's not
like I don't know it's just that I don't
have targets and and here's a here's a
useful example of where that got me in
trouble so like I said in the last two
weeks or three weeks or so I've actually
had targets and there was a day where I
was really
I was running all around the city
helping a student get set up with stuff
and I was feeling super lethargic super
beat-up like my blood glucose wasn't
stable but I went no no I told Berto I'd
be hitting 1678 on her calories today
I'm gonna cap it at 1700 and I woke up
the next day a full kilo lighter and
Berto was like oh what happened and I
was like I I turned into a traditional
bodybuilder who ignored everything
except the number that is on high come
down from from Dorian Yates and Ronnie
Coleman and they sold me it you will
lose your your status as a bodybuilder
in our community if you don't hit this
number and so yeah that was the lowest
way and I've hit I'm actually been
heavier since but look leaner and it was
just a state of being like super
depleted dehydrated and and it wasn't
necessarily a good thing that I saw that
number at that time right now you
mentioned like that you're low days get
pretty low how low is low for you for
like a calorie total yeah and just to
put this in context because I don't want
people thinking this as normal or or
recommended for someone who competes at
180 pounds but as a guy who spends most
of his time podcasting now we're sitting
at a desk I my low days have gotten down
to and again I'm three weeks out I'm
hitting 1,600 1,700 on my low days and
then my high days are around they
weren't 2500 and Bert on one of them
2,700 because I was staying flat even
after two days so right now the basic
structure is I have four lows three
highs so four days between sixteen to
seventeen hundred three highs around
2,700 as of late Berto has actually been
doing it more like an auto regulated
trigger for High days so once I sent him
pictures every few days and video in the
same lighting and then if he and I both
agree that I'm looking tighter or if I'm
looking really shitty like gross flat
then we trigger those three high days so
it's basically make progress kind of dig
a hold and fill it back up and we've
only been doing that for about a week so
I'm actually right as of today on my
eighth load day I had one medium day in
between so I had some meetings and
honestly that's
that's the biggest thing like I'm not
I'm not negatively affected in the same
ways I used to be like the hunger
doesn't beat me down too bad I'm not
craving to the same degree it's still
there but I feel like for whatever
reason that's something I can manage a
lot better maybe because my diet has
more variety or because I have the high
days but I get a little irritable I
can't focus as well I'm not quite as
sharp and I don't have patience for a
lot of social interaction so I went so
in Berto told me hey let's go another
another three lows and I'm like oh seven
in a row that'll take me to the s and C
meeting I'm like hey man can I get a
medium day-to-day just because so I'm
not totally depleted tomorrow from the
meeting and he was like sure so I got
like you know 2,100 calories and that
got me through my meetings without you
know getting fired or killing a student
so yeah in the universities these days
when you kill a student they get so bent
out of shape it's not like you know the
old your grandfather's academia no I'm
glad that you did that yeah we got a
change at the Times and it's something
I've come to learn yeah you know you
gotta accommodate the Millennial mindset
but so okay that's not too crazy like I
know Milo days when I was virtually dead
in prep you know it wasn't a typical for
me to get a touch under 1,500 you know I
obviously can compete a lot lighter than
you mm-hmm
now but one thing you mentioned in your
prep I guess one of the things I like of
how you phrased it is that even when you
go qualitative it's still quantitative
in nature you know what I mean so even
if you say well I'm gonna frame this
change as removing half a cup of
whatever from my diet you could frame it
qualitatively but it's still in numbers
driven change the numbers are what's
doing things for you so mm-hmm that's
that's why I was like you know for me it
makes sense because Milo days are really
low and I'm sick of staring at the
number so it's like hey Erik did you
remember you you only get 1,500 calories
today as a grown man I'm like you don't
want to look at that every day so I'm
like okay well I'll just do some
qualitative changes that are a lot
easier to stomach intellectually you
know yes I and and I I have found
that it is definite like my stress
levels my confidence believe it or not
my overall disposition and my ability to
live life like you know III will
actively sit here and recommend that
that unless you're a highly experienced
bodybuilder you should be tracking you
probably should have a coach you
probably shouldn't be eating out and not
controlling your own food intake more
than once a month during prep and then I
will turn around and tell you and guess
what I'm eating out one to three times
per week right now and I'm often not in
control of it but I'm I I am still using
quantitative numbers to ensure that my
qualitative assessments are accurate
like I've been losing at the rate of
weight loss that I should be at I have
glute striations from the sides like
glue serrations from the back and I'm
three weeks out I'm right where I should
be
can we can can we get a picture of that
for like the cover photo for this
episode when it goes up absolutely
and we're not even kidding I will give
you I will give you some shreds if
that's what you need brother just
specifically glute striations that's
that's all [ __ ] you just want a picture
of my butt crate I can do that well when
you put it that way it sounds quite
crass so what I what I said is a glute
striations okay so you want a close-up
of my glutes trations correct yes we're
on the same page now
if you watched Arrested Development when
they can't tell if the photo is actually
desert terrain or a person body we want
it to be ultra zoomed in glute striation
done done perfect yeah and it will
probably be actually did desert terrain
just just for fun that's a joke for the
for people in our Venn diagram with
people who listen to this and also
watched way too much Arrested
Development now you mentioned earlier
that your first I think 10 or so weeks
were not super tracked mm-hmm and then
the last X number of weeks were a little
bit more numbers driven
mm-hmm exactly how long is this prep
gonna be great question so you know to
be fair that is a few things that if I
don't put it into context it sounds like
Wow Elms is doing nothing like he
recommends so I started my prep on
December 18th my first shows in April
6th if you do the math I think that's
about a 15 week prep and you'll see most
the time I'm recommending 6 months for a
bodybuilder is kind of their baseline if
not a little longer because of where but
most people start but this prep truly
started at least the planning stage in
late 2016 where I finally saw the light
at the end of the tunnel after my last
data collection and after Hurricane
Matthew didn't destroy FAU and I
realized I would be able to finish my
last study because I was having Florida
for that with Mazur DOS and at that
point I was like alright I don't need to
be in the lab 60 hours a week anymore I
can actually train with the volume that
I know will will progress my body and
and have the recovery to not get broken
by that and I started training more for
bodybuilding specifically I also knew I
needed to get hip surgery which I did in
early 2017 and Rehab from that and then
started the proper offseason and I
worked myself all the way up to about
100 kg or 220 pounds for the American
listeners which is the heaviest I've
been since like 2000 geez late 2007 and
that was just binging post-show so I got
up to a peak offseason weight that I
hadn't been at for a long time and the
best it ever looked I was doing a lot
more volume a lot more body will make
specific work and then I knew that I
didn't definitely didn't want to start
my prepa 200 kg so in 2018 in April I
did a one-month mini cut and I got down
to around 94 95
so dropped about 10 pounds and then I
repeated that in September and then
accidentally kept repeating it into
October while we're in Finland so I lost
about another kilo while we were in
Finland Eric just because the I don't
know when I travel I just focus on our
name to get my protein in and then if
you know that the food available to us
really quite work or if it's really
healthy that I just accidentally lose
marks who are on our feet we're
presenting were running around you know
we trained a bunch while we were there
so anyway I accidentally lost like
another and an another additional amount
of weight so I mini cut for what would I
planned on being two four week periods
and one ended up me and one for week in
one six-week period and then I ate up
until December 18th so I had about two
months of getting myself eating as much
as I could and I I wasn't necessarily
being super quantitative there I just
wanted to feel like a regular human and
if I gained a kilo or two that I knew
that hey you know being whatever body
would I was was probably too light I
didn't want to have any diet fatigue
going into prep but I also want to be as
lean as possible so I started my prep
right around 88 89 so I gained like one
kilo from October to December and then
started dieting and what was
legitimately about 15 pounds over stage
weight and then you throw in a little
extra of water and glycogen loss I will
probably be on stage
shredded around 81 to 83 and I started
prep around 88 89 so that's still
probably the only time I think a 15 16
week prep is appropriate now that said I
don't plan on stopping after this first
show so I want to compete in July that's
gonna be at the muscle mayhem in
Sacramento we're gonna have our big 10
year anniversary of 3 dmj jeff is
planning on getting on stage and then
after that then it's kind of we'll see
what's up so I'm at least going to July
which puts me at G's I guess that's it
says it's mid-july it'll be December
January February March April May June
July will be at least eight months and
if that goes well and I'm enjoying it
and I'm not feeling like you know why am
i doing this to myself I might go
further there's a Singapore wbf show
that I might do while I'm presenting
over there if that works out there's a
local show and in New Zealand since my
mom's here now love to be able to you
know do that and celebrate with her here
and then he'll there's wbf worlds in New
York this year never been in New York
and if I actually you know still have a
brain and a body if I my November I
might even do that that that is
but I mean like like you said if you
start lean and you do it kind of
incrementally health more power to you
also I mean if the Singapore thing
doesn't work out you're there for a
presentation there's a show around you
could just do the presentation in trucks
absolutely and I think you'd get a
little more credibility to what I'm
saying - right
I mean why put up a picture proving that
you've been shredded when you can just
speak in trunks it's just my my
viewpoint personally I think I think
that was actually like an old Paul check
thing he said if if anyone wanted to
talk about like dieting or nutrition
they should have to agree to like do it
in a swimsuit you know and Paul Chuck
has always seemed super reasonable to me
I mean well yeah eighty percent of your
time talking about poop then you're not
really a practitioner are you yeah I was
about to clarify like that is not an
endorsement of Paul check generally but
sounded like yes or just saying that
just saying that that general concept
isn't isn't an original idea so so
Trexler probably shouldn't get too big
of a head cuz really he's just parroting
it's all check no ideas are new
you're just plagiarizing fault rec right
exactly for most of my work yeah now I
want to ask you a couple a couple
rapid-fire questions and then then move
on a little bit but a couple things that
I just like to hear from other people
who know what they're doing when you get
later in a prep with your resistance
training programming how do you deal
with you know generally your capacity to
recover takes a bit of a hit do you drop
volume drop intensity or do you try to
just keep things as is good question so
I did a few things this prep I made
myself adhere to ad load schedule every
fourth week and I had been doing it a
lot more reactive in the offseason just
like paint mainly by like when did I
actually feel like I didn't want to
train because that's abnormal for me and
I didn't want to train that means
something has something psychologically
or physiologic he's not
well and I would take a deal owed so I
set up my mesocycles just based around
in three weeks of pushing and then one
week of D loading and then one thing I
like to do so that I've been Aliyah
enjoy D loads and don't go into them not
it all aroused to train because I do
like well I'll drop my my sets down from
3 to 2 and I will just do one heavy set
and not necessarily try to hit like a PR
but if it's there it's there and I'll
push that to closer to 9 to 10 RPE but
safely and then I'll drop down and do
some kind of high rep work for the next
set unless it's a movement where that's
really hard fatiguing or I don't want to
do it because I kind of keep in the back
of my mind the deal it should be easy
mentally and physically so for example
if it's like front squats I'm not gonna
be like let's do a set of 20 because I'm
not because I don't want to do that you
know so that that's one one element of
controlling for fatigues I have these
mandatory D loads and then I've been
picking at the volume that is it all
redundant or is the most stressful so
some things that I've done for example I
have a day where I do a lot of
bodybuilding accessory work the day
before I do kind of a power lifter or a
big compound movement day and I had both
dips and tricep pushdowns on that day
and I was just feeling like this day's
taking forever I'm tired I just cut out
the tricep pushdowns
other minor stuff that I've been doing
is for example I was doing front squats
and also safety bar squats and we change
gyms and I swapped out the front squats
for a power squat and just having me and
when you're when you're this lean and
you just can't figure out where the
bottom of a squat is and and you just
feel like man your body just feels
different I really enjoyed being able to
have a more stable environment to Train
that movement pattern so I've done a few
things like that I've swapped out a
compound for a machine based compound
and that's felt better and yeah so I
think those are the two main things I've
done is just a little bit of picking it
some redundant volume
and then choosing movements that feel
safer when I'm this lean and then having
those mandatory fourth week d loads and
there was an initial drop in volume like
I went through two micro-cycles and in
prep and I noticed I'm just not
recovering the same way I think because
I started lean and because I started
with a relatively aggressive deficit but
not nothing crazy I'm still not losing
faster than like you know the point five
to one percent I felt it earlier you
know the kind of the old older approach
I would do would be start 30 pounds over
stage weight and lose a pound a week for
30 weeks and that's just such a small
deficit and you've got such a you know a
surplus of body fat that you know you
just don't get if I kitchen depleted if
I had to guess you know and you just
don't feel this beat up for a while and
I wouldn't feel the need to really
change my volume but this time within
two weeks I I'd noticed something so I
just cut my volume down by like we're
talking ten percent globally before
everything so there was a slight initial
cut mandatory D loads and then picking
and things to make sure that the kind of
the perceived RPE globally is a little
bit lower yeah I mean that's that's an
insightful answer but you know what the
problem is with you lab coat wearing
eggheads is that I preface that question
by saying rapid-fire round my bad
drop volume or drop intensity that
should have been a two-word answer Eric
you had a choices
I dropped volume a little bit and change
sizes no I mean I like that because it's
like from someone with your perspective
who does academic stuff who coaches
people who does it in the trenches it's
good to kind of take people behind the
thought process mm-hm and you know for
things that are supposed to be rules you
know drop volume well let's
contextualize that we're talking about
picking out non-essential volume you
know we're talking about which things
psychologically are a drag to do so that
I think you know the podcast format is
great for that you know we did those are
the things that don't find their way
into an article so it's a good
opportunity to get that same thing with
like macros like you should
tract macros but here's what it looks
like if you don't you know what I mean
and who here's who can get away with
maybe doing more lenient tracking yeah
and and this is what what what macro
tracking can look like if you build that
skill and not to get too meta and I'm
totally destroying this whole rapid-fire
situation with this comment but I think
my evolution to doing it this way kind
of comes from a meta shift in my
thinking as a science communicator and
researcher where we were focused so much
on the quantitative mechanisms behind
fat loss the obesity epidemic how you
get lean with some almost willful
ignorance and arrogance around not
paying attention to not being a
quote-unquote victim of or needing to
focus on the experience and just saying
well look you know my body's gonna fight
me screw my body and I don't care about
what leads to lower macros I'm just
gonna have them you know all the matters
is the numbers I'm of the machine
and I think that ignores so many
opportunities for getting better
outcomes by using biofeedback so anyway
I think that has echoes across my
experience in the last decade I would
say but yeah for sure now one final very
brief question here are you doing
anything to deal with the reduction in
neat or non-exercise activity
thermogenesis or are you trying to keep
a step count or like hey every couple
hours go take a walk around the block do
you do anything at all for that I did
start in one one of my first things I
did when I had a stall was I instituted
just two 30 minute cardio sessions that
were easy I wanted to keep them
something that wouldn't fatigue me and
then make me be even more lethargic
later in the day cuz I have noticed in
previous preps that if I do it it just
doesn't seem to like the math doesn't
add up and there is some research now
that if you look at it's more so on
obese people but where sometimes if you
do high-intensity exercise earlier in
the day TDE doesn't even go up not in
everyone but in some which is just wild
to me so I've been trying to kind of
sneak in some formal cardio as a way to
offset the the lethargy
yeah well I would agree one of the
things that I kind of went with my gut
on I'm out of the high-intensity
interval training game when I'm prepping
I said it crushes me I'm out and there's
no amount of research you could present
to me that is gonna convince me I should
do it again yeah I got I got scarred
with that no.9 and now I just do cardio
that I like and if I'm feeling it and I
want to go like push a sled or something
I'll do it but I've got to be feeling it
yeah and kind of an offshoot of that
question so you you're an evidence-based
guy in general is there an approach that
you advocate or implement yourself like
like what's the one thing you do that
you kind of swear by but has the least
amount of supporting evidence or is
there anything that that you do the
chair just convinced is actually
beneficial that there's actually
evidence against ya if you want to get
even spicier yeah so so one thing I've
been doing more and more lately that I
could probably like you know after the
fact justify based on some weird
research is that I'll have my last or my
second a last meal around like six or
seven and I feel like I'm normally good
like my hunger between my first meal my
second meal I leave my post workout
shake reliably goes down to something
manageable that isn't distracting and
then I can wait until I'm hungry and
that normally puts me with like the
three plus hours between meals that hash
tag and PS is is raced right but after
my last meal that I eat around seven
like my dinner when I'm kind of done
working out or not distracted for
whatever combinations of reasons I'm
ready to have a second dinner
immediately and I almost always just I
basically only make it like an hour and
a half two hours and I eat again and I'm
sure the Lucene gods don't appreciate
that and it it probably doesn't make
sense but it makes the diet overall much
more sustainable like last night I had
dinner and then two hours later I popped
up in a can of tuna and had
had that and I'm sure there's a 2007
version of Eric who's screaming about
maximizing the impulse area under the
curve of my mps per day so but it helps
and so you're willing to stake your
entire reputation on that strategy
you heard it here my reputation state is
there anything like that you would say
you think is like the thing that a lot
of body builders are doing wrong
currently is there like one thing that
sticks out to you that you think a wide
range of body builders could drastically
improve yes I do actually and this is
something I've talked about before but
there was that I want to say 2013
interview or a questionnaire of a ton of
body builders and asked how they trained
and I think two-thirds of them train
with a once per week weekly split and
then one third of them trained with a
still a split but only trained twice per
week and while I don't think the
research on frequency is nearly as
convincing as say effort or volume it's
not like I don't think those are three
equal influencers or determinants of
hypertrophy volume intensity and
frequency I do think that having a more
appropriate frequency will probably
optimize things in the long run and I
think that body builders should probably
be training each muscle group a minimum
of twice per week and it's interesting
to me that that is the minority and no
one trains anything more than twice per
week not deep do you think two is the
sweet spot or are you thinking it might
even be higher than that I I feel like
it should be that seems the minimum
based on what I've seen and I think the
main reason I want people to experiment
with different things is not because of
again successive hashtag spikes in MPs
it's it's more that I think body
builders focus too much on the
experience of a single session rather
than the global management of fatigue
and stress and I spent an intentional
couple years playing with upper lowers
full bodies and splits
see how many sets per muscle group could
I get in a week while having it feel
qualitatively easier even though it's
more sets and what I landed on
personally was full-body five days a
week and being that being slightly
better than than six upper/lower
sessions because I find if I can spread
my specifically my lower body compounds
out over the week each individual
session gets easier and then I can pump
out more upper body volume now to be
fair that strategy makes sense for me
specifically because I tend to have a
hard time growing leper body and my legs
look pretty good on lower volume and
tend to be a little bit larger on
balance so that might not make sense for
someone who is you know top-heavy they
might need to be take a different
strategy but for me like I I go in there
and I have one main lower body compound
lift per day or I have one day where I
just do calf raises and then I just do a
lot of upper body volume I get way more
total work done per body parts that need
it and I feel much more recovered and
that has been really nice during prep to
not have to go great I have leg press
rtl leg extension leg curl and calf
raise today that sounds that sounds
really not doable
it's like oh I have safety bar squats
and that's it yeah and then I can move
on until you know yeah it can be one of
the lateral raises I can move on to
chest press and and stuff that that is
more fun for one and that you can you
know see yourself looking awesome in the
mirror which which is silly and
narcissistic as that is like one of the
saving graces I find motivationally when
you get to a certain point and prep it
is training with less clothes on in the
gym with good lighting and mirrors
because then you can look past the fact
that you feel lethargic or that maybe
your weights have gone down slightly and
be like man this this is a lot of fun I
look great and then you kind of forget
the fact that you were only thinking
about pizza an hour ago so you you
preface that by saying you think that
frequency probably isn't as important as
something like volume specifically for
muscle growth or intensity for strength
gains but so with anything like that
the thing that I
a the thing I always wonder is when we
look at research even meta-analyses on
studies that run you know eight 12 maybe
16 weeks is I wonder if if things that
seem to be better in the short term
actually work out to larger benefits in
the long run so for example have can you
think of any examples that you
personally know of someone who you know
had already been lifting 8 to 10 years
already gotten quite big seem to be
either at or close to their quote
unquote like genetic limit who then like
changed training frequency and gained a
notable amount of additional muscle or a
situation like that because the thing I
wonder is like you know maybe these
things are better for like making gains
faster and maybe like you eventually hit
a plateau and you know six years instead
of ten years but you're kind of winding
up in the same place regardless like
does that make sense it does make sense
and the short answer is yes I've
definitely seen that and that's actually
a relatively common experience with some
of our clients and this is actually a
relatively common experience I've had
when I can convince a bodybuilder to
give it a shot and try it for a while
the thing is is and to get kind of into
the mindset of a bodybuilder and I know
Eric you'll appreciate this it's it's
very difficult to have a session that is
that has a moderate feel and what I mean
by that is if you look at the dominating
paradigms of training and bodybuilding
you either have failure and post failure
training kind of the Dorian Yates esque
approach which forcibly limits you to
your volume and your frequency or you
have the marathon sessions where you are
sweating you are burning if you think of
kind of the clips from pumping iron
there probably is a little bit of
failure in there but this drop sets
there's giants that's you're doing a lot
of work and there's a very little
promotion of anything in the middle like
but that's been around but if this
doesn't gain popularity like Brian hay
Cox
a chesty that's a great example of what
is kind of was it was evidence-based at
the time where you go right we're gonna
take the volume that you do on any
single day and then just let it out
spread it out over 3 full-body sessions
because that makes the most sense based
on the evidence and this was been around
since the early 2000s with some great
examples of people have used it
successfully but but has never caught
fire and the reason it didn't catch fire
is it doesn't align with the ethos that
body builders have in their brain which
is it's all about hard work there's got
to be a healthy bit of masochism and
each session needs to feel hard and it's
very difficult to enjoy your training if
that's not the case so I think for me
too when I try to sell someone on this
I've stopped focusing on hey have you
read a Gregg's open-access meta-analysis
I'm stronger by science on frequency I
stopped taking that tact and I start
taking her well it's in there it's in
there but only if they're super nerdy
the but the main convincing factor is I
go like I tried to get him to start
focusing on their logbook more because
it really starts to pay off in terms of
their strength levels become much more
because their recovery is a little more
homogeneous they can push harder
their training lifts more frequently so
they can they can reap the rewards in
their log books a little more so kind of
and that is something that's gained
popularity ever since like DC came on
the scene when people like always beat
the blog but let's beat the logbook so
they can more quantitative bodybuilder
who enjoys seeing progress and can
convince themselves well I must be
working hard enough because I am
progressing my lifts tends to do pretty
well with this approach because they
don't psych themselves out they don't
feel like man this is easier than
anything I've ever done
so I think I think yeah it's it's one of
those things that I have seen it work
quite well and I've probably been able
to sell it to people just on the fact
that hey I'm a 3d MJ athlete now I want
to be part of the crew they all say it's
good and now I believe in it so
obviously it's not like an RCT but I've
seen it time and time again be effective
in high-level athletes who've tried
going from a once per week split two
more and one final comment on that
before you chime in is that I've seen a
lot of people get net worst results
because they don't understand
how to moderate individual sessions
they'll go from training on a Monday
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday split
your standard bro split and then they'll
switch it to like legs chest and back
shoulders arms six days a week but
they'll keep the amount of volume per
muscle group the same per session so
they basically double their volume and
then they get rekt and they go yeah that
was too much you can't recover I'm going
back to once per week or they keep going
to failure so it's it's one of those
things where they're unwilling to
compromise on the whole reason that
bodybuilders train once per week is that
they take each session to the house and
if you don't take it all the way to the
house it allows you to more frequency
and it might be better in aggregate but
if that's a non-negotiable then you're
never gonna see that now that's a
perfect segue so you're mentioning
bodybuilders there's that kind of
masochism tied into it you know it's
especially late in prep it gets a little
bit a little bit gritty I recently found
myself in the hopefully metaphorical
crosshairs of a fitness industry
influencer I was talking about
bodybuilding
and they said that I was a shitty person
because I had not forcefully condemned
the practice of bodybuilding and used
the term physique athlete suggesting
that bodybuilding was a sport hmm so as
a person who's been in the bodybuilding
game forever what is your comment or
your kind of response to people who say
bodybuilding is unhealthy you know it is
essentially a competitive eating
disorder it shuts down your your body
when you prep what do you say to people
who kind of kick back against
bodybuilding and say it's a pursuit that
people ought not pursue you know first I
would say I really understand where
you're coming from to that person and
that it can it definitely can be all
those things but something that can be a
certain way is not the same as something
that is inherently that way an eating
disorder is an eating disorder a you
know masochism is masochism bodybuilding
can lead
to eating disorders or exacerbate them
or might attract people with them and
can have masochistic elements but they
are not the same so what I think that
means is that we need to have a little
more nuance in care and also
consideration in the way we talk about
bodybuilding which I absolutely agree
with and these days I am much more a fan
of someone becoming a quote-unquote
lifestyle bodybuilder because I think we
almost say like a recreational lifter
with derision you know if someone is
trying to look at to figure out what's
the leanest physique that they can
maintain without any kind of negative
effect without being in a state of low
energy availability while also having
built the most muscle mass they
appreciate that look there's an art ism
to it there's empowerment and that truly
I think is healthy because they're not
in a diet at state and they're trying to
build symmetry and they're kind of a
throwback to the the kind of the Grecian
ideal and they're appreciating the
symmetry and proportions they see their
body as art I think there's a lot of
really cool things in bodybuilding that
don't require you getting on stage now
if you do decide to compete in that and
take it even further I think it's just
the same as any other sport in that
there is a trade-off between health and
performance
now just like again any other sport the
the range of those trade-offs spans from
you know natural bodybuilding and
competing in one of the divisions it
doesn't require quite as much leanness
all the way to I'm trying to get an mr.
Olympia win in a bodybuilding class
where I am going to be okay with trading
a couple decades in my life and needing
to be on HRT for the rest of my life if
I and maybe not having kids and stuff
like that on the other side of it and
and yeah I think the answer is that we
just need to be very clear with the
potential risks like I mean you could
say the same thing about gymnastics
where if done in the way that results in
optimal performance we're hopefully
stunting puberty and in in small gals at
a young age we're recruiting children
when they don't necessarily have the
agency or
the legal consent to release a they want
to compete in this we're encouraging
them to suppress their energy intake and
then we're while we're doing that and
potentially inducing a loss of you know
bone mineral density via nutritional and
hormonal factors we're then going to
slam them as hard as we can into the
ground and just hope they don't get a
stress fracture and then tell ourselves
that the fact that they have this
high-impact training is offsetting the
fact that we've suppressed their their
natural maturation but that's fine well
for for something for something even
less extreme because like you know you
bring you bring kids into it and
automatically then you're dealing with
more like well do they understand what
they're doing et cetera
mm-hm even for something less extreme
than that
like endurance sports like elite
endurance sports for female athletes
also like even if they're old enough to
know what they're doing you see a lot of
amenorrhea you see a lot of stress
fractures you see not all all the time
but often you see like a pretty big loss
in bone mineral density even before
menopause so mm-hmm like yeah you're
you're also dealing with a lot of issues
there as well but people don't demonize
that nor do I think they should I think
people should before they do something
they should know what they're getting
themselves into and if they know what
they're getting themselves into and they
want to do it sure like be my guest I
don't care I agree and with that said I
do I do really think that that
bodybuilding as a competitive endeavor
that you stick with for your life it is
among if not the highest potentials for
having a negative some negative negative
effect at least temporarily maybe early
when you first started competing or or
something that becomes kind of cyclical
and those who stick with it long term
typically figure out a way to make that
not the case so I wonder how much
survivorship bias we see and I mean that
may be it maybe it's true of any
aesthetic sport that requires you to
kind of really always be focusing on
your nutrition in a way that is not the
way humans would like to focus on their
nutrition which is you know culture
action motion in sustenance but always
about kind of monitoring it and focusing
in Milan external cues I think the fact
that your quote unquote practice comes
home with you all the time and each time
you step in the kitchen really makes
aesthetic sport as overall and
especially bodybuilding have a higher
potential harm so you really need to go
and devise wide open and I'm all about
convincing people to be a bodybuilder
who doesn't necessarily get on stage and
only if you were truly have the calling
yam it's just something you really want
to do and you understand it should you
do it but I really think the sport is
for a very small minority of of crazy
people that I'm proudly a part of yeah I
mean I know your guys's sentiments I've
done Studies on gymnasts good luck
finding a 22 year old gymnast that
doesn't have at least one surgery scar
and you know I've done research on
retired football players they die
younger than people that didn't play
football you know I mean it's to echo
what you guys have said it's do you know
what you're getting into and I like the
you know Eric you mentioned with with
natural bodybuilding you can adapt your
approach and find a way to interact with
the sport in a way that isn't just
neutral to your health but actually a
positive influence to your health
whereas yeah so that's actually a really
good point Eric I think that's something
we there was a study that just came out
of Finland again to keep talking about
our our time there nostalgically where
they showed the the overall like heart
health of a bunch of gals who went
through contest prep there was markedly
improved even though they started at a
BMI and activity level that was well
within and passed to the health
recommendations so so by getting over
lean and doing more exercise training
that was already reaching the standard
their heart got even healthier at least
by that the metrics they use so it's not
like contest prep automatically crossed
the board black and white bad for you
but I think you're a hundred percent
right it can be a healthy endeavor
especially if you're doing it drug-free
and we shouldn't ignore that even though
it does
essentially come with you know just at
least at least temporary disordered
eating during during contest prep or
immediately afterwards yeah I mean I
love the way you talk about bodybuilding
I mean it's it's part of you now so the
thing I couldn't help it but I mean when
I heard I was a shitty person for
promoting bodybuilding I was like dude
they need to have like a UN war crimes
tribunal for Eric Helms if promoting
bodybuilding makes you a bad guy you are
like one of the sickest people on the
planet right now I'm pretty much a like
a Chechnya war criminal who was who
slaughtered children yet you are the
worst of the worst now and you you have
a podcast now where you kind of talk
about like lifting culture right do you
want to plug that real quick yeah so to
kind of dovetail off of this I think
maybe one of the reasons why I'm not
quite Slobodan Milosevic is because I
look at bodybuilding with a bigger lens
than what is the current culture of
bodybuilding when I say I love
bodybuilding and I I appreciate it
there's a lot of people who don't relate
to the way I relate to bodybuilding who
are very high level competitive
bodybuilders they don't feel like it's
part at all they're not interested in
the qualitative experience they do look
down on people who are quote unquote
lifestyle bodybuilders they think if
you're going to use that title you
better be getting on stage and they
compete to win and it is their life and
if you're not doing it that way you're
not hardcore you don't really deserve
your bodybuilder card but I really
appreciate the art the history the ethos
it came from from physical culture some
elements of the Grecian ideal although
not directly related to it and those are
all things that we explore in iron
culture which is a podcast that myself
and Greg chuckles that's hilarious
that's not the person that Omar Issa
started with me I mean ultimately I'm
the person behind the scenes yeah it's
true we're all Greg knuckles
I am knuckles is I think that anyone who
watches Walking Dead will get that joke
so yeah iron culture is we take
a holistic look at lifting culture from
a societal cultural historical and
scientific perspective so as an example
we had on dr. Mike Soros Mike to shear
and John Kiley to talk about auto
regulation and periodization for two
hours and then we also had on Peach
deadlift Ben [ __ ] the strongest
freaking 93r on the planet who got his
doctorate in physical culture and sports
studies and his colleague dr. Dom mores
both just to talk about the history from
the 1700s to the 1900s of early lifting
in the West and then we've also had John
meadows and dr. Mike Israel to talk to
us about Frank and honest conversation
about steroids so it's it's just life
decisions culture history we've got a
lot of cool episodes coming out so it's
very much trying to create unity and
awareness of the depth and the richness
and the issues of both contemporary and
historical in lifting culture awesome so
if you're listening go ahead and check
out Eric's podcast it sounds like they
have a wide variety of really
interesting topics on that Eric thanks
so much for coming along with us today
we really appreciate your time and if
people want to get in touch with you how
can they reach out to you okay a huge
pleasure and I'm really glad you guys
have a podcast because I love listening
to you both talk and thanks for having
me on so yeah if you want to learn more
about me or what I do or read or listen
or watch my stuff go to 3d muscle dirty
comm that's the best one-stop shop you
can find links to mass you can find
links to my book you can find links to
the 3d MJ vault where we do our courses
for bodybuilding and powerlifting and
you can also find links to our podcast
and our blogs which I'm on regularly the
3d MJ podcast the other one I do so you
can get all of our free content you can
get access to paid content if you want
to go that route and then in any only
things that aren't there as my instagram
handle that that's at Helm's 3d MJ and
then iron culture podcast which you can
find on itunes spotify and youtube
excellent well we're about to sign off
thanks everyone for listening thanks
again to ericom's for joining us and we
will see you on the neck
episode thanks for listening to the
stronger by science podcast now Greg and
I are not experts in medicine or health
or really anything else for that matter
so before you make any changes to your
diet and exercise habits make sure you
check with a doctor or another health
care professional if you enjoyed this
podcast and you'd like to support it
visit stronger by science com to check
out the products and services that we
offer thanks for listening and we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you